hey guys I apologize for the bit of
confusion that I calls with episode 104
and 105 accidentally put the title and
thumbnail of episode 105 on episode 104
and that just turned into a bit of a
weird situation and that is also why I
forgot to upload a video for a week
while I didn't forget to upload a video
for a week but actually forgot that I
had already made episode 105 so I was
kind of busy this week and I thought her
I've no video to release I'm sorry guys
but to know that I had a video on my
computer this entire time so I'm sorry
about that in any case this episode is
gonna be a bit of a less interesting
episode I mean at this point the
victorian tea cups ride is pretty much
finished the entire little tea house on
steroids is all done and the only thing
that was really left to do in this area
is path works this episode is just going
to be path work it's not just the shapes
but also the defenses and things that I
wanted to add on and around them but
yeah that's something that I can't avoid
and the promise concepts of this entire
series was to record everything so I'm
not skipping anything in my videos but
do you understand that this is not going
to be the most interesting video for
those of you weren't really interested
in path work because that's the main
thing that's going to happen in this
episode that doesn't mean by the way
that I don't think that path work is
relevant now it's something that I just
feel like people often underestimate how
important it is to get your path work
done in a good way since it really lays
the foundation of what your Park layout
is going to be and I feel as if
buildings that are really good but
placed in a very bad not so coherent way
with just terrible Park planning is
almost a bit of a waste of good
buildings and so especially for this
area since I wasn't even sure what sort
of theming and buildings I wanted to get
around it I really wanted to make sure
that I got the path work done right now
about those buildings the only thing
that I'm going to be planning in this
area around the roller coaster is the
station itself which I'm not sure yet
how I want to do this station since it's
it's a bit of a hard theme English theme
is something that I've rarely ever seen
I think
haven't ever seen it except for like
rural small parts and to be very honest
I still have no idea how I want to do
this station in the future but other
than the station I won't have any
buildings around the volley coast itself
just foliage but that right that Rocky's
sort of terraforming that you can see
right there next to the corkscrew that
is going to be a flat ride most likely
going to be a ferris wheel because
somebody gave the recommendation to try
ferris wheel since its you know long and
I and that stuff and figured that
circularly really good idea so I'll try
to get that in and next to that is going
to be a really big string of facades
which is going to lead all the way back
to the Train where I'll just have these
sort of standard English row houses in
either Victorian or stucco Styles those
are both things that I still need to
look at especially the buildings that i
already have since I'm definitely going
to have to make some custom scenery to
make it more realistic than it is right
now since with alpine village you can
come pretty close to a tutor look but I
am really missing out on the Tudor roses
and I got actually some really good
feedback in the comments so I'll
reflects on that and see how I can
change the building's to make them a
tiny bit more realistic than they are at
the moment so that's also something that
I want to do the only real special thing
that I want to get in building wise is
I'm gonna have a weenie in this area I
can't not have a weenie over here and
the main weenie is going to be a big
Tower and like the Elizabeth Tower in
London or the town hall in Manchester I
think that i mentioned before now that's
one big problem since there isn't really
too much because some scenery using
which you can make things like that so
it's basically to get the realistic
tutor look to get some more realistic
washed out bricks and to get pieces to
build english clock towers that i want
to make some simple custom scenery it's
not going to be a lot of stuff but it's
something to keep in mind since it's
gonna take a tiny bit more time to
finish this all since the cosmos in
remaking is something that i don't
include in the videos but it does
actually take a bit of time for me so
yeah that's why i might like a tiny bits
on how many videos i'll record in the
future plus i am pretty busy now one
other thing that I might actually want
to do which is nothing to do with the
last place but I really feel like I have
to do actually is got back to my two
soils I haven't done one in a very long
time and I've still got a bit of a list
of things that I need to do / people
have asked me to do and one of the
things I would actually like to try
first there's an asian tutorial because
I see that the Asian theme is becoming
more popular recently but there's couple
of things that I would like to say about
it in other case that was very off topic
I'm just you know talking much stuff
because this is not too interesting
actually I did have a bit of an
interesting discussion in the stream
since once one thing that you'll notice
about this roller coaster is it comes
really close to the paths which is of
course the goal of this thing was to
have a lot of paths and scenery
interaction to make it look as
interesting as possible I mean it is a
B&M stand up after all but one one thing
about that is that these fences are
quite low so there was a bit of a
conflict like should I make the fences
higher which would actually like lower
the aesthetic value than it has right
now because that's one of the things I
like about this area is how accessible
and open it all looks like paths are
going everywhere there are there's a lot
of very detailed gardening and it looks
very open and inviting and the problem
is as soon as I add very high fences
around the roller coaster tracks which
are everywhere around the path over here
I would break up that openness and but i
know i would like break down that
openness that was a bad wording so yeah
I kind of don't want to do that but on
the other hand it is a lot more
realistic because technically right now
children can well not like little
children but bigger children and people
that lost I caps on the ride and want to
get that kept back can climb over the
fence and be killed by the roller
coaster so that's something to keep in
mind but I think my final say in this
entire thing is that i'm gonna keep
these fences low i'm not gonna care too
much about okay that sounds really bad i
was about to say i'm not going to care
too much about the safety of my guests
no i find it important but i want to
keep that aesthetic value to it and i
feel like these fences are just good
enough to not let people without common
sense past them and to let people with
Colin Sens understand that they should
not pass the [ __ ] roller coaster
track
so yeah I just don't want to make this
entire thing look like it's a deal so
that is why my fences are somewhat low
see if this was real life that would be
more of an in-between option but since
this is what the co second three and you
either have one H fences which are low
or you have to edge fences which look
like you're trying to lock people up in
your Park there is not really some in
between a sort of action that I can do
to make the park like safe and inviting
at the same time so that's why I would
like to go with the low fences rather
than yeah the very high ones so yeah I
do realize and I am aware of the fact
that this might not be the safest way to
go but I feel like it is just safe for
this area so that's that plus people
need to make their way through an
abundance of flowers if they ever want
to get to any of the roller coaster
tracks over here this was actually
something I think I kind of forgot like
in the entire making of this park I
forgot to actually have these signposts
not say where you need to go for what
and it's not just a good idea because
technically it's a very realistic thing
but um it's fellow and awesome pitiful
path works is always amazing so it's
essentially the same thing as a sundial
or a little fountain just trying to get
a little centerpiece in your path work
which is something that's I know it's a
bit of a tough thing because you got a
lot of useless stuff about your park in
a way since you'll notice that many
people in raleigh co 2nd 3 spam
fountains and sundials like it's their
daily job and an unrealistic amount of
Sun dials and fountains often happens
whatever you can Billy place in the
center of a path but still I would
probably argue for doing this stuff
because otherwise you get those really
launched path areas and usually in real
life you to have many people walking
around them and you don't really notice
how empty it is but the thing is a park
looks a lot different when I know people
in it and this also counts four loko
second three the only problem is that
the peeps are ugly so I would like my
products actually look good without any
people in them and look better with
people in them which is what they
usually do which is why I would like to
keep
open spaces non-existent in my Park at
least large open spaces in real life you
can have really wide pathways in disney
for example there will be many people on
it and a lot of entertaining stuff going
on on the pathway which makes it more
interesting than just an empty large
wide pathway but in what the Costa can
three don't really have this which is
why at least that's the sort of a small
theory that I have why people really
like to span little part elements to get
that emptiness out of their paths which
is also why I do it and to be honest
it's something that I'm really not
against it does work aesthetically so
yeah that is why you'll see me placing
many more sundials in this park how I
think yeah I've already got two sundials
in this one in the image area and
there's one in the Spanish area and to
be very fair who even reads sundials so
I'm as pretty pointless plus I also need
to figure out since one of the ideas of
the park was also to get a signature
flag post him in every area where I've
got the flank post for Spain up in that
one large building of the Spanish area I
still need to get an Italian flag
actually don't have that one yet I would
like to place that one in the little
Italian town for some that I have
currently the Dutch flag is of course in
front of the stain of the estate tration
I was about to say that um I'm but in
front of the train station and that is
of course very well I think it's a good
location for it very visible and very
central to that area but for the English
area I have no idea because I feel like
popping a flagpole on top of a Victorian
tower is something that I should avoid
doing so I still need to figure out what
would be the best sort of area for the
beautiful English cross so I'll see
actually no it's it's not did i do I
keep calling this area England mmm it's
Achille perfect OPP thing I haven't even
realized that I haven't even thought
about whether i want to make us england
or Britain as a whole though I think
it's just gonna be England so i might
make the English flag on a nerve like
this but um that's very your topic I say
that I'm running out of time so thank
you guys for watching and I'll see you
guys in the next episode of it is in